[Music]
[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
sponsored by mastercard
a quiet place will be getting a third
movie that will be a
spin-off set in the quiet place world
and is being written and directed by
jeff nichols
john krasinski who directed and co-wrote
the original 2018
film as well as the yet to be released
sequel came up with the idea for the
spin-off and will serve as producer
plot details are being kept under wraps
for now but the film is set to be
released in 2022
kristen bell and jonathan groff who
respectively voice princess anna and
kristoff in the frozen movies
will be reuniting for a live-action
musical
the musical is titled molly and the moon
and hails from directors craig thompson
and carter bays
the creators of how i met your mother
the two stars will play parents to be in
the movie
who sing to their unborn baby in the
womb isabelle furman will reprise her
role in an
orphan prequel according to variety and
the actress will serve as an associate
producer on the film
in the original 2009 film she played an
adopted east european child with an
incomplete historical file that leads to
a shocking reveal
deadline reports that julius styles has
also been cast in a role for the movie
which is titled orphan
first kill
well the holidays are just around the
corner and if you're looking for a
little inspiration to get into the
holiday spirit don't panic
we've curated a list of the best holiday
movies to watch at home
seriously there's nothing better than
curling up on the couch
and watching a holiday movie marathon
and here to guide us through some
personal recommendations
is rotten tomatoes correspondent naz
perez
hey there naz hi kale how are you
i'm great i've got a really difficult
question for you though what are your
favorite holiday films of all time
okay so you know how right now we're in
that time between halloween and
christmas
yes well i picked two films that are
honestly
so perfect for that time my first one is
the nightmare before christmas it is one
of the best disney movies ever an
animated classic brought to us by tim
burton
i think this film is perfect for the
entire family and i love it because it
can get you in a really spooky mood but
also a really festive mood
so if you've never seen this movie it's
about the skeleton named jack
he's the pumpkin king he lives in
halloweentown and he's sort of bored of
this halloween routine
but then one day he discovers christmas
and what christmas is and basically
tries to take it over
it is so much fun especially for kids
that are just trying to grasp what
christmas is like seeing somebody
discover christmas for the first time
it's also very immersive like it's a
musical so if you guys already
know all the words you want to learn all
the words it's very interactive in that
way
and i just love this film because
halloween and christmas are my favorite
holidays and it meshes
both together perfectly so the nightmare
before christmas is my first
recommendation
and stop motion is a signature of the
holidays you have the like little
animated
stop-motion rudolph one and all that
stuff like that and so
having nightmare before christmas is a
stop-motion is just it makes sense so
that's a great pick i watch it every
year so i
totally agree great pick oh thanks kale
i agree and the stop-motion animation if
you're into art and all that kind of
stuff
it's also a great reason to tune in
because i would argue that this is one
of the best stop-motion films ever made
what's your other pick okay so my other
pick you know i love rom-com so i had to
throw a rom-com in there
um and it's you've got mail which stars
meg ryan and tom hanks who just have
the best chemistry ever in this film it
is
their third appearance together that's
how amazing their chemistry is
and if you guys have never seen you've
got mail it's basically about two people
who are in
an online romance and they are unaware
of the fact that they're both
business rivals so they both own
bookstores on the same street it is
completely unrealistic
but you know pale that's why we love it
especially if you're a single person
watching from home like me
but also like i feel like all i have to
say is tom hanks in a christmas movie
you know this man should be like in
every christmas movie ever
his character joe fox owns like the
cutest dog named brinkley
has tom hanks ever played santa claus i
was just thinking that like we've seen
tim allen be santa claus but we need to
see tom hanks i think tom hanks
he was in polar express he was in polar
express
and he was the the guy on the train and
i think no wait he was santa in that
movie too
oh he's tom hanks with santa and polar
express okay yeah but we need to see
actually yeah we need to see him in the
garbs
yeah yeah he's he's ready he's ready
he's ready it's time another reason why
i just
love you've got mail is because dave
chappelle is in it and so many people
forget that he's in this movie
and he has a bunch of scenes with tom
hanks and it's really fun seeing them
act together
you guys have got to check out you've
got mail younger people might actually
enjoy it too because the way they
communicate is by
email so it's it might be kind of fun to
watch that i didn't even know it was a
christmas movie i didn't
really think about that i know well i
was telling you before i started
i picked two movies perfect for this
time because it doesn't start out in
christmas it starts out in new york
in the fall and then you know we get a
little bit of the christmas vibe and
that's why i love it it's not like
christmas overload but it does take
place over the holidays and i agree with
you young people are gonna love this i
was just thinking about
how exciting it is opening your laptop
or your computer back then
and like waiting to hear you've got mail
and seeing you know an email from
someone that
you're romantically it's its own
christmas present
in itself ooh oh it's like
you know yeah in the vein of holidays do
you think there's a holiday that
deserves more films about people coming
together
okay so i think we have a lot of films
about new
year's eve i don't have a film that i
love that takes place on new year's eve
that i don't feel like is really
cheesy but if i had to pick one holiday
that we need more movies about it would
probably be groundhog's day
because groundhog's day with bill murray
is one of my favorite films of all time
i just love you know the groundhog trope
of like reliving a day over and over
again
why isn't there an animated movie about
groundhog's day it could be about the
groundhog
i agree oh my god we need a stop-motion
groundhog somebody call tim burton kale
that's genius
yeah tim burton yeah that'd be amazing
this is why
you know fandango rotten tomatoes it's
it's a beautiful partnership
all right well thank you so much for
joining us where can people find you you
guys can find me on all the rhyme
tomatoes social channels or on instagram
and as perez
awesome happy holidays naz you too happy
holidays and happy new year kl thanks
for having me
available to watch in theaters friday is
freaky
seventeen-year-old millie kelser played
by katherine newton is just trying to
survive the halls of blissfield high and
the cruelty of the popular crowd
but when she becomes the newest target
of the butcher her town's infamous
serial killer played by vince vaughn
her senior year becomes the least of her
worries
when the butcher's mystical ancient
dagger causes him and millie to wake up
in each other's bodies
millie learns that she has just 24 hours
to get her body back
before the switch becomes permanent and
she's trapped in the form of a
middle-aged maniac forever
[Music]
and available to watch at home on friday
chick fight
when anna wincombe is introduced to an
underground all-female fight club in
order to turn the mess of her life
around
she discovers she's much more personally
connected to the history of the club
than she could
ever imagine the film stars bella thorne
alec baldwin and mullen ackerman who
also served as producer on the film
alright well that's it for today but
check out that full list of holiday
films in the link below and leave us a
comment and let us know which one
is your favorite i'm kale and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you